what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am here
in utah with my best friend in the
entire world brooke
hello
um today i am gonna have her rating red
pill coaches just based off looks alone
she's never heard of any of these people
uh are you excited
i'm so excited
okay wait
um before i start guys do not forget to
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos okay
so i'm going to show you the guys and i
just want to say like
you just have to say like basically if
you would
hook up with them and date them oh okay
um a wood eyes should say you because
today it's just you this is just based
off of looks like you're not gonna do it
too i'm gonna do a different video
because i wanna do like i've heard more
of them talk so i think that affects it
oh that's true yeah talking does ruin it
okay um so these are all of them but
we're gonna go to the next page so you
think you're high value okay
so yeah
so this guy is 55 or
50 to 55 i think okay um he's six four
and that's what he looks like um
he looks really good for being 50 to 55.
i kind of like his suit i would go on a
date with him okay would you just hook
up with him
um i think i would rather go on a date
with him than just hook up with him he's
not like i wouldn't like see him and be
like oh like let's go you know what i
mean okay
next one um this is we're gonna do the
guy on the left first okay um so he's i
think he's 35 and he's around six four
okay
um
he wouldn't catch my eye i don't think i
would do either
okay guy on the right
um the same same z's okay
oh oh he's 6'1 i think but yeah i think
he's 20 these are just guesses because
i'm not overly sure okay um so this is
mediocre tutorials and reviews so i
think he's around six one to six three
um this is a terrible picture but he
really doesn't have any good ones um and
i think he's 35.
um i took up with him i like his tattoos
he looks like he has good arms okay
um so these are abba and preach these
are again guesses i think he's like five
eight to five ten range he's like six
one six two range on the right okay um
yeah this is what they look like
wait is that oh shoot oh
that's him and that's him yeah it's like
the same two guys style's so different
yeah that is well the guy on the left
are stay the same
well his no his hair is different yeah
yeah okay um
i know they have good smiles
like there they look really happy okay
um
i think i'd hang out with them feel the
vibes okay and then decide so they'd
kind of be like like you might you might
not just depending on them i'd
investigate okay they're really cool
actually i really like think that you'd
like them they have good vibes okay so
these are the roommates podcast um i
want to say they're around six foot i'd
say like late twenties early thirties
yeah
i'd go ahead and do with them or hug up
with them they're cute okay
that's it okay how'd i do
um
i think actually
i would agree
with
most of your assessments to be honest 50
would be too old for me
i think it would be too old for me too
but he does look good for his age no he
doesn't perhaps yeah he does but like i
just it's too old
but let let us know in the comments what
you guys think and i'm gonna do an
assessment like myself but i've already
heard because i think girls
the when we hear people talk it affects
more of the way we view them so i think
i'm a little too biased to do like a
rating on looks alone um but i'm gonna
do that in a different video but let me
know in the comments oh wait oh my gosh
actually before i end i want you to rate
all of them like from
i didn't i forgot i was gonna do this
um so rank one def like like
who's your yeah who's
for like a date or for what um let's do
hook up first um
probably him
okay so in the so she pointed to
mediocre tutorials and reviews okay
who's number two
um
um i vote
this guy
okay so on the i forgot his name but he
from the roommates podcast on the right
i actually think
the guy on the left is cuter than that i
was debating two one would be two and
one would be three two three so
roommates would be two and three yeah
okay
um
four
i i'll say
this guy based on this picture he just
looks really happy there okay so that's
um have one preach that's preach so
that's four so you should put preaches
for okay and we'll do then abba's five
okay so
so you do mediocre tutorials and rev
reviews and the roommates then ab and
preach then the old guy
um okay then the old guy so then kevin's
okay
and then probably him and then him
okay
i had a feeling fresh and fit would be
less wait are those the guys you're
meeting um i may be i think so maybe
when they see this they won't mount me
up
oh my gosh no i didn't show it on the
page
oh my gosh can we redo this whole thing
well that which is not me as genuine
or more as natural okay well hold on
guys i'm gonna no we won't redo it guys
i'm just gonna show you the pictures she
was reading i'm sorry i suck
i totally thought i shared the screen
but she put on mediocre tutorials and
reviews first she put
um the roommates second so she put
um did you say hafiz was second or third
i think i said two three okay so she put
the i don't know not hafiz the other guy
a second haffiz is third
um preach then abba
um then kevin samuels then
um myron then fresh okay
sorry honestly though i actually might
the roommates i might switch it i don't
know
you'd put you'd put roommates as one
yeah oh you'd put
a second yeah
um i'm actually surprised that you put
um
yeah i was surprised because i think the
fees is cuter than the other one they're
both cute but like i think hafiz is
cuter
but i have to check them out
okay guys um i thought this was again a
little too biased for me to do it
because i've heard them talk too much
but surprisingly i think your answers
would be similar if you heard them talk
i think you would vibe with abba and
preach probably a little bit like they
might go higher just like based on your
values and like i don't know like who i
could see you getting along with but for
the most part like i think you would
have like fit
okay cool okay guys just to meet them is
that the next surprise no
okay guys don't forget to subscribe to
the channel bring that notification belt
and
let me know what other coaches you want
me and brooke to rank